and i'm chairing the meeting today
i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
don't interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave the keith
please ensure hearing
mobile phones are on silent or switched
off
i would like to remind everyone present
at this meeting
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and
to the possible use of those images and
sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
or broad where am i or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
so um by way of introductions
we have we have one officer who will be
attending to speak today and that is
samantha lake who is the corporate
manager for customer services
so can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
i'll now ask the governance officer to
roll call for the members present
yes champ uh i will be
uh roll calling in alphabetical order
and can you please answer
with a present councillor dawson
president we have received an apology
from councillor gould
councillor grandin president
councillor mccraw present
mclaren present counselor osborne
presence counselor carter
president uh councillor hadingham
president
and i'll just be checking in counselor
carsten are you here
that's fine thank you chair
thank you uh we now receive declarations
of pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare
none thank you can we now turn to the
minutes of the meeting held on
june can we confirm the minutes of that
meeting
of the joint overview and scrutiny
meeting the meeting held on the 22nd of
june
that's item agenda item three
there are two amendments to add in
paragraph 4220
to add jan councillor grandin asked the
following questions
and the bit to add is which had been
forwarded to her
from a constituent and
in paragraph 4239 to add
in relation to how the income from cifco
supported gateway 14 and then a full
stop
and delete the word and
does anyone else have any other points
on the minutes the accuracy of the
minutes
please i see head shaking
so that as there are none could i have a
proposal that we accept the minutes
please
winningham has proposed and uh
councillor muller i think is
seconded i'll be the second chair thank
you
um so can we now
i will have a role in respect of whether
or not we can accept
those minutes so roll call vote please
thank you chair can i ask you please to
reply with for
against or abstain counselor carter
four uh councillor dawson
four councillor grandin
four councillor hattingham
paul councillor crawl
councilman mccraw
okay i will turn to councilman craw in a
minute counselor mclaren
for counselor muller or
councillor osborne cancer scarf
oh councillor willem
councillor mccraw can you hear me i can
now
i'm for the motion thank you very much
thank you and that's carried thank you
very much
so the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed
and they will be signed at the next
practicable
opportunity
to item four which is to receive
notifications
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petition
scheme do you have any petitions
non-receive chair thank you do we have
any questions by the public
none received and then on to item six do
we have
questions from counsellors non-received
chair
thank you thank you
so we will now move to agenda item seven
which is the joint compliments comments
and complaints policy and i'd now like
to invite
samantha lake the corporate manager for
customer services
to present the update to members on the
compliments
complaints and comments processes and
policy please
good morning everyone so i'll just now
um share my screen as i will be taking
you through a presentation this morning
just give that a moment to load
hopefully now everyone can see my screen
so um this morning i'll be providing you
with um
more of an update and it's specifically
not just focused on the
compliments comments and complain policy
but also
more broadly around customer service's
performance
and also some of the updates so the
areas i'll be looking to cover as part
of the presentation today will be
regarding
an update following a report sent to
overview and scrutiny
in december 2017 with a focus on
telephone performance
specifically that there was an average
wait time during 2017
of two minutes 33 seconds and a high
abandoned rate
this is also an opportunity to provide
an update to overview and scrutiny
regarding a report in july 2019
regarding the compliments comments and
complaints process
specifically focusing on the
introduction of an online system in
august 2019
to capture customer compliments and
comments and complaints
in one place and i wish to provide some
the initial trends that have been
identified so far
i'm also keen to update um overview and
scrutiny
on some of the changes that we've
experienced in customer operations
since the report in 2017 including our
refresh customer strategy
and the fact that customers is one of
our six key strategic priorities as part
of the corporate plan
so i wish to provide some updates on the
journey of customer operations since
2017
and some of our future plans
so um just by way of a visual journey
of our customer services developments
between 2015 and 18 there was a number
of
wider and sort of technical developments
if you will
across our customer directorate
including the merging of it
systems one contact center number skype
for business
and the office 365 rollout
in 2018 we launched a refreshed customer
strategy
started to deliver pop-up customer
services from shortly and hadley
libraries
as well as our customer access points in
stone market in sudbury
and also provided assisted self-service
in hadley library
through the use of a free-standing
tablet
as well as experiencing some improved
performance and the start of a
face-to-face satisfaction
survey in 2019
a corporate manager was recruited and i
started in um
late february of 2019 and we digitized
our feedback system
so compliments comments and complaints
started to deliver
the eu settlement scheme providing
face-to-face services for customers
who needed support with accessing and
applying for the right to remain
in the uk as a result of brexit
we also introduced a pilot telephone
customer service survey
and commenced work dual skilling our
team members
so moving from them being skilled in
either housing council tax and benefits
or
general services to having two of those
skills
it was important from our telephone
survey um to do this because we
identified a high volume of customers
that were looking to ask us multiple
questions regarding different service
areas
therefore dual skilling the team allows
us wherever possible to resolve our
customers queries
at the first point of contact rather
than being transferred to different
offices
we also undertook some visits of other
councils to share best practice
such as aylesbury vale wigan and
redbridge to help
us to start scoping out our customer
transformation programme
and we've also focused on using data and
insight to help inform our decision
making
as well as capturing the voice of our
customer through forums feedback and
surveys
we conducted our first customer forums
in december and january
with over 146 people attending which
consisted of members of the public as
well as some of our town and parish
councils
we also heat mapped over 1 000 user
journeys as the forums specifically were
looking to gain vital feedback
on how our customers interact with our
website
following this work and some subsequent
analysis we've recruited an additional
web coordinator
to start with improving our website and
this role started in the last month
we've also recently recruited a customer
access officer
looking at specific digital inclusion
projects
to help with delivering digital skills
work across our districts
and understanding the wider benefits for
our customers for being online
in november 2019 we refreshed our
customer access point in stone market
and implemented some self-service
tablets
and a new face-to-face satisfaction
survey using a tablet
for both stone market and sudbury this
has allowed us to gain additional
feedback across those two areas
we also delivered in january of this
year our first cohort of behavioural
insight training
to help us understand how we can use
different behavioural insight techniques
to communicate with our customers we've
digitised our freedom of information
and environmental information regulation
requests
and in late january we also implemented
a new telephone
um system called 8x8 which is
cloud-based
and has allowed us especially since
lockdown to deliver a virtual contact
center
without needing to be based in a
physical location
this has allowed us to ensure that we
can still provide valuable support to
our customers during this time
as well as taking on additional service
areas such as the support
of the home but not alone telephone line
and also capturing requests for
businesses reopening during
the easing of lockdown also
so just moving on to some of our
customer transformation program
so we have a number of projects that are
running concurrently and are reported
through our customer transformation
programme board
this is made up of a number of roles
across the organization and allows all
customer related projects across the
organization
to be reported into one board to ensure
that we're collectively meeting our
strategic customer priority
as part of that work we continue to gain
feedback from our customers both
internally and externally to help shape
future
future iterations of this work to
provide a quick overview
we've themed the projects of our
customer transformation program into
these three
areas their strategic tactical and
cultural
our strategic projects are the
overarching and underpinning strategies
and activities
such as our work that will be commencing
shortly around business process
re-engineering
where we'll be looking at streamlining
our processes
ensuring that they're simple and clear
for customers are easily accessible
and they make the best use of technology
such as automation
strategic projects also include some of
the work we're
undertaking at the moment to scope out
our digital skills work
for those customers who wish to go
online to access access services
and ensure that we're able to do so
using community partners to help deliver
some of this support work
our tactical projects are the specific
projects that will help us to deliver
the change
such as the implementation of our 8x8
new telephone system
which has provided us with the
opportunity to deliver a remote contact
centre
the digitisation of some of our key
processes such as freedom of
information and environmental
information regulation requests
which not only allows customers to raise
these requests online
but over time allows us to create a
database
so customers can search through some of
those frequently asked questions
rather than having to submit new
requests
also um following on from some of our
web
forums a key trend that came out was
that customers are really wishing
to use services such as chat bots and
over the next few months we'll be
launching a pilot
which considers automated telephony and
chat bots for environmental services
such as waste
so that customers can complete
transactions such as renewing garden
waste services
using either automated telephone
services and chat bots
24 hours a day some of our cultural
projects
are those that support with ensuring
that we're creating and embedding
a customer-centric culture across the
organisation
and some of this work has included the
launch internally
of our customer charter which ensures
that we have a clear set of standards in
relation to customer services
expectations across the organization
and also providing opportunities for
upskilling
um offices in areas such as behavioral
insight
so to provide an overview of some of the
customer services performance following
the 2017 report
i wanted to just share some of the high
level updates for the last year
so in the last year we've received over
132
000 calls which represents a 14 decrease
from last year
we've achieved an average answer time of
1 minute 37 seconds
which is a reduction of 56 seconds from
2017
and achieved an 87 answer rate
which is similar to last year's level
however we are constantly looking to
improve our performance
and so far this year we've already
achieved in april a six percent
abandoned rate and average wait time of
43 seconds
and over may and june a 5 abandoned rate
and an average answer time of 31 seconds
we've also responded to nearly 20 000
customer emails which represents a 22
increase from 2018 and recognizes that
shift
that customers are wishing to contact us
more online
we have also supported nearly 7 000
customers
across our face-to-face services in
sudbury stone market shortly and hadley
however this does represent a 25
decrease from last year
we continue to look for ways to improve
our performance and ensure that we're
providing customers with the very best
levels of customer service
something that's particularly important
in that space is to ensure that we're
capturing customer feedback
to ensure we understand how they feel
about the services we provide
as this aids us to further transform
some of the work that we're doing in our
customer transformation program
and ensure that customers really are at
the heart of everything we do
in 2019 we introduced a pilot telephone
survey
and surveyed 847 people on average
they rated our service 9.9 out of 10.
we'll be shortly reintroducing a survey
to ensure that we can capture ongoing
feedback about our telephone services
specifically focusing on the changes
that we've made around dual skilling
our officers so that we can understand
how many of our
customer enquiries are resolved at that
first point of contact
our satisfaction levels for face-to-face
services have also been consistently
over nine out of ten
throughout the last few years and we've
received an 88
first point of contact resolution rate
in our face-to-face services
we also wanted to get a better sense of
how people felt about the services they
receive
through our face-to-face offer so we
implemented a touchscreen feedback
tablet in november
last year and as part of the questions
that we asked
we asked how likely our customers were
to recommend the services we provide
to friends and family through a net
promoter score
the net promoter score um categorizes
customers
in terms of whether or not they're a
promoter of the service
neutral or a detractor from that you
then
minus those detractors away from the
promoters school
and it gives you a total score out of a
hundred between november and february we
scored 65 from those results
whilst that's good and we understand
that the uk average from a customer
services institute report in july 2019
that the uk average net promoter score
was 22
we are constantly looking for
opportunities to improve our services
and i'll touch on some of the areas that
we'll be
looking at shortly
lastly and we also introduced a website
feedback button in december of last year
as part of our website forum work
and this has shown that customers rate
our pages on average 2.9 out of five
as customers can provide individual
feedback on the individual pages of our
website
this provides us with an opportunity to
weave this feedback
into the work that will be shortly
undertaking around improving our website
to measure the impact of customer
satisfaction over time as we are making
those changes
another key way in which we understand
how customers feel about the services
that we provide
is through the recent implementation of
our compliments comments and complaints
feedback system
this has really allowed us to capture
all feedback in one place to ensure that
we can identify the trends and lessons
learned
for greater service improvement as part
of our customer transformation program
some of the key trends that we've
identified so far is that whilst 54
of our complaints were not upheld some
of the ones that were
really fell under contractor error at 41
and process error at 27 for those that
fell under contractor error
largely these were to do with things
such as delayed or missed bins
and these can be resolved um in 24 hours
and the waste team endeavor to inform
customers through daily updates on our
website to identify delays
and help to better inform our customers
when these things happen
but also our process improvement work
that we'll shortly be undertaking around
business process re-engineering
will help us to better understand some
of the processes from a customer
perspective
and over time help to reduce the level
of complaints that come through
regarding process improvement required
we have also seen an increase in
complements over the time that we've
introduced our feedback system
and i've included a couple of recent
examples of our compliments
to give you a sense of the types of
trends that we see in our complements
so the first one was to do with
supporting a customer during covert 19
with a council tax bill planning um
and often our compliments are to do with
where officers have shown empathy during
difficult circumstances and provided
valuable support and advice
for areas such as council tax and
housing over the last three months we've
also
seen around 50 of our compliments
related
to the work of our waste collection
crews
and the support that they've been
providing during the pandemic
so just to go um into the performance
update a little bit more regarding our
telephone services
so we have seen a reduction in calls
over the last year of 14
and we have been dual skilling our team
over the last 12 months
to ensure that we can manage the call
demand and also support customers with
their multiple queries
rather than having to transfer them to
different offices
whilst we have seen a similar abandon
rate to 2018 as you can see the most
recent performance has shown that we're
really making some strides in improving
that
some of our busiest times of the year
that reflects some of the peaks that you
can see
in the graph specifically around council
tax
billing period where we see a much
higher volumes of calls
also election periods where we see
highways we have high volumes of calls
and in february there was a real spiking
cause to do
with the storms that we experienced and
specifically customers wishing to
um inform us about repairs that were
required as a result of damage that had
been um undertaken to
um fences for example during that time
um as you can see this the cool split by
team
and our general services take the most
calls so they're 40
of all of our calls and this um is
predominantly down to the fact that
often a caller has multiple
questions and they don't sit neatly
under those areas
but also they are responsible for
manning areas such as public realm
requests
environmental requests and also general
is where
all of the calls have been manned for
our covert 19
home but not alone response line so that
we were able to provide
customers with support with things such
as food medication and social isolation
during that time
and we'd taken over 900 calls um during
the last few months
our council tax and benefits calls make
up the second highest proportion of all
of our workload
with 61 and relating to council tax
inquiries
such as um direct debit payments or
um things such as applying for um
changes in circumstances around their
council tax and benefits also make up 25
of our council tax and money matters
calls
and rent inquiries are the third and
highest with
seven seven percent of all of our
council tax and benefits calls
housing make up the last area with 24 of
our entire call volumes
and 61 of those are related to repairs
and 17 related to gateway to home choice
bidding
so in terms of our face-to-face services
as i mentioned we have seen
our face-to-face services demand
decrease over the last 12 months by 25
and the main reason that our customers
come in to see us and over 60
of those inquiries relate to um
providing support with
providing evidence or uploading
information
filling in forms and viewing information
online
and 88 of those who have come in to see
us have said that we've been able to
resolve their query at the first point
of contact
some of the feedback that we've been
able to glean from our um
self-service tablet has been that people
really appreciate the friendly and
helpful nature of our team
and the welcoming environment that we
create across our customer access points
and also anecdotally that since the
implementation of our self-service
tablets in stone market
people find that uploading information
themselves
via the tablets is quick and easy to do
therefore we're currently undertaking
some improvement work to ensure that we
can support customers using community
partnerships
to provide more local support to help
deliver
digital skills training and support to
customers who are not currently online
or would like to improve their digital
skills and we look forward to presenting
our phased approach to this work over
the next few months
and hopefully you can see it takes into
account the queries that we receive to
these customer access points
and the fact that people find working
with the self-service tablets
and to upload information quick and easy
to do
so what's next for customer services so
i hope you can see that we've undertaken
some significant
improvement work since 2017
not only to improve our performance but
also our services for customers
and to ensure that we understand what's
important to our customers
and also sharing some of our wider
ambitions as part of the customer
transformation program
especially with regard to improving our
website
implementing new digital systems and
also
our call center improvement work
and also our upcoming work on digital
skills business process re-engineering
and automated chat bots and telephone
services pilots
we've been able to so far use these
improvements to identify even more
opportunities to improve our services
and ensure that customers are at the
very heart of everything we do
we've also recruited some key roles such
as our web coordinator additional role
to help with web improvements
and our customer access officer to help
with delivering the improvements and
ensuring that we communicate
gain feedback and use data and insight
to ensure that we're
effectively communicating with our
customers but also ensuring
that nobody is left behind so
that's everything from me thank you very
much and i'll now open up to any
questions
thank you very much indeed that was an
excellent presentation
um we can see that there's been
continuous improvement over the last
three years and
we can also see that there was a good
response to the covid
19 emergency
so um thank you for that i'm now going
to ask questions i'm going to use
roughly alphabetical order but not
necessarily starting
at the top of the alphabet um so
if i could take questions first from
members
and any debate we will come to later on
so this is
purely for questions of the officer
and i'm going to start with councillor
lavinia hattingham please
um thanks oh that was a great
presentation sam um i'm
really excellent and i'm i'm just
pleased to see that we you know that
things are improving i haven't really
got any specific questions i was gonna
say well done
thank you thank you councillor mary
mclaren please
sorry having trouble with the the video
you can hear me that's good sam that was
brilliant
in a time of bad news that was really
reassuring can i just ask about the
charter
is that actually now agreed or are you
developing that
so um it has been agreed and we'll be
looking to launch that externally over
the next
few months and presumably then we will
get as a
committee we will get a copy of that to
have a look at
absolutely yeah well thank you very much
well done
thank you councillor david muller
uh thank you chair uh again samantha an
excellent presentation
uh i was particularly interested in the
number of uh complaints of 402
complaints you mentioned and you did
show some of the breakdown of the higher
ones
would it be possible to see a list of
the entire number of complaints at all
that would be quite interesting i think
for me personally absolutely i'd be more
than happy to share that after this no
problem
thank you thank you thank you chair uh
councillor adrian osborne please
thank you uh thank you chair yes um i've
got nothing but
uh absolute delight to see the uh
position that you had from from the
early days when i can remember
uh quite a lot of uh member um
complaints themselves about the way that
the
the website was it was being tackled and
also the
number of uh uh people that were getting
in touch with uh
uh with with with sudbury town council
in for instance
and our own district council so
i think the improvements have been
absolutely marvelous and i
i think what you've done is is excellent
i can't
i can't say enough uh about it and
the thanks must go out i think from from
all members perspective
i can't see any reasons for
uh any problems with this and uh
thank you very much uh mr chairman thank
you
thank you councillor keith scarf please
thank you chair yeah um i was just
wondering uh accepting that um
the number of physical sort of
face-to-face um
visits has gone down um yet again
are there any plans at all that you're
aware of to
to reduce that opportunity or are you
planning to
still continue with that opportunity
because i think it's important that um
we do recognize that some people don't
like doing it other ways or
are unable to do it other ways
yep so um i think there will always be a
requirement to have some level of
face-to-face
um support for our customers i think
what we're looking to undertake
is some work to provide those customers
as well with opportunities to go online
where that's something that they want to
do and understand more about
um digital skills support so we will be
looking to share with members
um shortly a phased approach to that
but ultimately we'll be looking at
providing more local opportunities and
working alongside some of our
community partners to deliver more and
local
services to customers who wish to access
that type of support
so definitely we won't be um removing
any face-to-face services
thank you thank you um if i could just
follow on from that
is the decrease in the face-to-face um
visits similar across all of the points
of contact or is there one or two of
them that are
going up or going down rapidly is it or
is it roughly similar across the board
it's roughly similar across the board i
think more notable ones are stone market
and sudbury
um when we look at the sort of numbers
from 2018 to 2019
shortly have have always had lower
numbers and i think they've seen 28
people
across the whole of the two years and
we've been delivering there
and but broadly it is a similar picture
across the board around
a decrease thank you
councillor terence carter please
oh yes um well questions
i do have a question regards whether or
not to be term
customer implies a matter of choice i
know this
is a report on customer services but
if somebody's phoning about a repair to
a
house i think they prefer term
constituents because otherwise having to
move to get
this service is a bit extreme
i do also have to ask about whether or
not the uh
the report still exists from 2018
where mid-suffolk disability forum was
visited regarding the inaccessibility of
the stone market drop-in session
as far as i'm aware no changes have been
implemented and we've never got any
feedback
regards to how the access could be repo
improved to go into the building and
into the
room and last one so um
is regards uh if somebody is in a phone
call and there's
multiple issues that they have to raise
does that just count as
a singular complaint or are the
multiple issues logged separately
so i wonder if that would actually have
a if say
missed bin delivery happens at the same
time as
something else or rather would that just
be one complaint or would it be
different complaints together i've run
out love the presentation
and uh thank you very much but yes
thank you okay do you want me to answer
those so um
in terms of the work that we did with
the mid suffolk disability forum
we did engage them when we were
undertaking the review work of our
customer access point in
um stow market to understand from their
perspective what improvements could be
made
and i have engaged um with the chair of
of that particular forum and those
improvements were made
um to explain that i think um due to the
fact that kovid
19 happened we haven't been able to um
bring them back
in to to view all of the changes
specifically and but
linda hogarth is aware that those
changes have been made
and but more than happy to share some of
the feedback
and separately with you if that's useful
and but specifically it was to do with
things like signage
and ensuring that there was appropriate
um wheelchair turning space
um but we had actioned all of those in
particular areas
in terms of multiple issues being raised
so on the telephone then all of those
areas would be logged
separately if they were requiring
intervention
in terms of a complaint it would be down
to the customer if they wanted to raise
that separately
or um they wanted to kind of build it
into one complaint
and we would just deal with those
appropriately the lessons learnt though
would be captured um in the same way so
that we can understand exactly what
areas came back as a result of that
um i think that at some point the the
committee are hoping to visit
the customer access point so we will at
that stage
i mean after the restrictions have been
lifted we'll be able to see
what changes have been made or perhaps
have not yet been made and will be made
so i think that will be that will be a
useful visit in due course
thank you um the councillor
sean dawson please um yes thank you
that's an excellent presentation the
only thing i was sort of
querying really was um i think you
mentioned in the first one of the first
slides that the
um call wait was two minutes 33 seconds
and then later on in the presentation
you were talking about an abandonment
the 14
now is that really accurate across the
whole year because
um you know what what i
a lot of feedback i get from people is
that they get through
um but they never quite get to where you
know where they want to set up a direct
debit so then they abandon the call
so i'm just sort of wondering to what
extent if that phone call is answered
you
presume in your analysis here we're sort
of saying that yes we've dealt with that
when actually we haven't in reality
are we able to get that information
um as to how many phone calls are
actually made as opposed to how many are
abandoned
so abandoned call specifically relates
to when a customer has not got through
to somebody on the phone
so they've abandoned the call yet um in
terms of customers that have not had
their queries resolved um regarding
things like direct debits
um we do undertake um as all of our
calls are recorded we undertake
um cool recording analysis to understand
the services that have been provided
and that's why we're looking to also um
start this
um telephone survey to see how many of
those queries were resolved at the first
point of contact for our telephone
service and hopefully
that will provide um more information
around those
um customers who don't feel that they've
been supported fully on the phone
and if there are any instances of that
that you wish to share then i'm
more than happy to look into those cases
as well for you well i just wondered
it's just like for instance
i i just get the impression that people
are fed up with calling in but then of
course the numbers will have gone up
because of covid19
so which might then flatten this year's
figures out so it looks like we're
trying bundling along quite well when in
fact people aren't making contact
and i certainly um i i know myself i've
tried to set up things but i just
wondered whether we're not quite getting
the figures the real figures because of
the covid and i
and i just think people are not really
getting through
and i'm just surprised the figures are
as low as you're saying they are
so and some of the figures were not um
including the kovic 19 um
pandemic they were kind of over a much
longer period of time
um but but more than happy to um
to share when we start some of the um
the new telephone service um survey
sorry
some of the results that we get back
from from that um
in terms of customers calling us we
still see you know as i mentioned
over 132 000 calls a year so it's still
quite a significant
number of con customer contacts um
in into our services thank you
my understanding from people i've talked
to about setting up direct debits
the problem isn't with the call it's
with the
caller's own confidence about doing
what needs to be done and so i think
some
who i've talked to have abandoned it
they've got all the guidance that they
need but then they've thought
well this sounds a bit complicated to me
i'm not going to do it
and i think that's where the community
projects and
helping people over that hurdle of
confidence a lot about i think is
is confidence rather than ready
i'll give example i had someone actually
only a couple of weeks ago he's been
flying since um
february for a garage to set up a direct
debit
they can't they they've emailed to
customer services because we have it for
council tax
then it says to set up a direct debit
you have to talk to one someone because
of the covered nobody's actually there
so they're still not doing it and they
get apparently caught
these sort of every three month letters
which is more cost to us
but i just thought oh gosh you know
that's just a typical
sort of thing and and they must go on
all
the time really well perhaps that's one
to take outside of the meeting
and to have a look that's why i was
wondering really as to what extent
many of these calls are abandoned and
how many are really actually
followed through to the end anyway thank
you
yeah it might be worth having a look at
that so somebody to have a look at that
to see if that is something which
might have happened to other people but
it might you know
there may be very they may be very few
and far between
anyway um we have got to the end of
questions unless councillor carter i
think still got his hand out do you have
another question or
can it be included in the debate
councillor carter my apologies to the to
my system
is showing this lowered i've tried
lowering again having a bit of issues i
apologize
right and counsellor councillor um
grandin sorry i
i uh i hadn't come to you so
if we could counsel the brandon please
thank you
thank you um yes excellent presentation
and i'm really pleased to see how the
system's improving
um as you're aware though there was a
an instant um about a week and a half
ago where i contacted
um sarah because of an outage of the
telephone system
um i had a number of people contacting
me
sorry can you hear me
can you hear me yes i can hear you yes
um
where i had a number of people
contacting me because the whole
telephone system has gone down um so i
i believe this was an unusual situation
but has it been rectified
and will that um has it been
examined so that this can't happen again
or
hopefully it won't happen again could
you give me some feedback on that please
yep absolutely so um yes unfortunately
we did experience an outage of a couple
of hours of our
um contact center system it is the only
time that's happened
um and unfortunately it was to do with
our provider 8x8
and it happened across the country so it
wasn't specifically focused on
our services but all eight by eight
services across the country
it has now been rectified and we have
been working
with our eight by eight um telephone
provider to ensure that that doesn't
happen again
and but also ensure that we have um
other plans in case
there was a longer outage around um how
we would provide those telephone
services
but it was up and running within a
couple of hours and i can only apologize
that any customers struggle to get
through to us during that time
what we were able to do was anyone who
was getting in contact via email
we were calling them back via skype or
teams
and just to ensure that we could still
communicate with customers
if they were able to contact us via
email but
yes apologies that that did happen it is
the only time that has happened
and we're confident that it won't happen
again thank you
i have another question as well if i may
um
the face-to-face um contact
um i'm glad that it seems to be
successful with regard to hadley and in
fact i am
surprised that as many people do attend
the service as
as they do which i'm pleased about i
think it's a very good service
at hadley library um so
so that's um great news the statistic
statistics you provided um regarding
the reduction in the number of people
using services in general
um face-to-face does that include
um this year since covid or is that
um prior to that so they were reducing
anyway
it is prior so i didn't include any of
the impacts of covert on our
face-to-face numbers as i thought it
would be disproportionate given that we
were in a lockdown period yes
absolutely good um and
so do you assume that those people would
have been dealt with by telephone or
other means
um yes um so
we we were um supporting customers um
who were struggling to for example
complete forms and we were talking them
through
how to do that um on our telephone lines
um it did mean that some of our cool
handling times were slightly longer so
um occasionally we would spend
an hour on the phone to someone just to
make sure that we were able to support
them in the best way possible to
complete those forms
but obviously that gave us a sense of
reassurance that they were able to do so
and we were able to see that process
through to the very end with our
customers
um so yes we were able to provide
support to customers on the phone
where they've not been able to come in
to see us
great i'm sure that was a great comfort
and help to them thank you very much for
that information
thank you counselor thank you um
councilman mccrory you've got your hand
up is that an accident all right
oh i do chair it's not an accident for
once i'm glad to say and i will take my
hand down
uh first of all i'd just like to thank
sam for a really
encouraging presentation the journey
referred to in slide three
is one that many members will recall
when overview and scrutiny first started
looking
at this subject in its particular and
and in terms of customers complaints and
compliments and also
in terms of phone response times and i
think a drop from two minutes 37 seconds
to figures of below a minute is a
remarkable one
um and i appreciate that people have got
issues about the use of the word
customer
as opposed to resident or a member of
the electorate whatever
fundamentally though in experience um
organizations that have a
customer-centered
focus regardless of whether those people
have the choice of going elsewhere
it's the very focus of these those
people as individuals
as customers we treat them as though
they do have a choice
because we value them anyway um
regardless of whether they could
can't go somewhere else it's a point of
an attitude and i think that's the
crucial point to get across here
now always all this stuff has been done
i do have some questions involved in
this
uh i'd like to ask sam though we've seen
um
an approach to a public face the way
that uh
the council officers um and staff can
deal with the general public
and they're one part of that public face
members
are the other part of a public face of
the council
and i'd just like to ask sam if this is
not a static process
what um thoughts have been given to
member involvement
in keeping this going forward to
bringing members
into the process of improving customer
service as a whole
um thank you so um i know you've
mentioned this before and i and i feel
really passionately about ensuring that
our members and feel really engaged with
all the changes
in customer services um i would like to
take that one away just to think about
that a little bit more
just to ensure that we have um that we
do engage you i know that um we've
recently done a customer briefing
um to members and i think that's a nice
way to engage
um members in some of the developments
and but also some more kind of informal
um ways to do that so um i will take
that away as a really serious point
because i completely agree
um it is absolutely you know crucial
to ensure that you are engaged
throughout all of this process
as um as as key kind of extensions of
our customer services
and support really so yes thank you for
that thank you supplementary on that
chair
certainly yes well the reason i mention
this is that very much i suspect from
hearing the other members questions and
from the questions i suspect that will
come up
in debate is that it's very easy for us
to give anecdotal evidence on individual
cases
but of course sam is here is presenting
an overall picture
based upon a proportion of statistics
and some
means of communicating these anecdotal
pieces of evidence
so that sam can then take them if we go
through every example for example today
that any of us might have come across in
our own work experience in our wards
i suspect we're going to be putting sam
on one a spot she can't answer in an
individual circumstances to
somewhere where she possibly shouldn't
be answering on individual circumstances
and three
we might end up going in circles i just
add that because i think it's important
not to get uh
overly focused on the specific where we
can't control it and sam can't
necessarily answer it
uh but to deal with the general thank
you
chair may i just interrupt you yes um
sam
um i think you might still be sharing
your screen
oh apologies sorry
thank you you're welcome sorry i thought
i'd
turn that off i think it was a bit slow
on the uptake apologies for that
that's absolutely fine it's just a
public view and people can see what's
going on that's fine thank you
thank you very much um councillor
grandin you still have your
hand all right sorry sorry i didn't
realize i did
um so other
are there
no chair i think people have asked the
members are asked their questions so
right thank you very much so um can we
now move on to
a debate um can i ask for comments now
from members please
and i'll go in a completely different
order um somewhat at random
um counselor david muller do you have
any comments you want to enter into the
debate uh
no comment at this stage thank you chair
thank you very much
councillor osborne
councillor spawn can you hear us or are
you on mute
we'll come back we'll come back back to
the council
um councillor grandin would you like to
make any comment or
and yes thank you thank you um i was
pleased to
hear in one of your comments or answers
to questions that
the face-to-face service um although
it's reducing in need that there are no
plans to
withdraw that service um i do think
that's an important
um service to have um
available to customers and residents
um so and and i know some of the older
people in our community
find um face-to-face service an
important
um part of what we offer
um and uh they're not so confident
with the um
alternatives although obviously we have
uh
hadley and elsewhere got um the
um screen there for people to use
but i just wanted to say i i'm glad that
that
is something that you're planning to
retain and i hope that's going to be
ongoing thank you
thank you very much councillor hadingham
um thanks no i haven't really got
anything i'm extra to say i i want to
echo what catherine said i think the
face to face
we are going to have to keep going with
that even in a very small way but um i
think it's all good stuff and yeah well
done again
thank you very much councillor mclaren
thank you chair uh sam i just want to
comment on the
dual skilling um all of us have suffered
from ringing into organizations and
being passed from pillar
to post i think that is excellent
and well done to developing that thank
you
chair thank you very much counselor
keith scarf
thank you chair yes i mean uh just like
um the previous speaker i think the
dual skilling aspect is is one that's
really critical
um otherwise you do get pass from pillar
to post
i'd like to say that i think excellent
progress has been made since 2017
um with the team and it's important that
whilst we recognize the changes in the
way that our residents contact us
that we do continue to operate that
face-to-face system
i just think of my 91 year old mother
who would be
unable to access technology even if
given the training frankly
um and therefore that one-to-one
face-to-face is is so necessary and it's
something that councils when they look
at
and i can remember when we had a
different format at
ipswich street in stone market we
decided to abandon that
because of the cost per visit um
there's always more than a physical cost
per visit and i think it's really
reassuring to know that we're continuing
to operate that service even if it's
need is reducing
and i'm also pleased that the telephone
operators are able to
offer assistance to residents with
complicated
uh requirements and and needs
and devote that time to them because
quite often when you
phone another public body they really
don't have the time
to devote that that to you and i suspect
i suspect that um the other means of
accessing
uh our customer services are enabling us
to
spend more time with those who
particularly need help on on the
telephone so
well done samantha and the team thank
you very much
macro yeah i'm just
really sort of happy to see this um this
approach having come to fruition over
the period of time
that we've we've been looking at it um
this is more of an observation um
i've been banking for many years with
one particular bank and i'm
well they consistently come in the top
three of customer service organizations
throughout the country
and this is universal ever since they've
been in operation and that's first
direct
um it's a phone banking service that
also uses uses online but
on the sheer matter of personality
friendship offered over the phone but
it's a bank but you're not expecting
them to be nice to you
and they are and and i know this sounds
really um i have been saying this all my
life
i must confess my life has been spent
largely in the
matter of customer service and um
and smiling at people smiling down the
phone
effectively smiling through the internet
wherever you can i cannot
stress how important that is not only
does it make the process easier for the
end user whatever we might call said end
user whether it be customer residence
constituent whatever that person is a
person
they need to be appreciated as such and
here's the funny thing
the people on our end of the phone
ourselves included
we have a better experience out of it
simply by having that
warmth and that empathy which was sam
referred to
it's so important that this stuff can be
more enjoyable
more productive because it's an attitude
it's an approach
and it's something that can be if not
enjoyable
certainly a lot more bearable and that's
typified by
my experiences with that particular
organization
i have noticed that it's a point that's
spreading
across customer service organizations of
all sorts
i've even had friendly conversations
with the aaa
and insurance companies this was not
considered possible only oh i don't know
five
ten years ago so i hope that
we can bear in mind what the good
experiences we get from customer
services elsewhere
and bring them to bear upon our own
services i think that's the crucial
point
this is a matter of attitude
and it's in to everybody's benefit to
act this way
i think that's the most crucial point i
would stress to members
to the public obviously to all our
officers and i have to say
sam since she came into post last year
has
absolutely exemplified that approach and
i can
only commend her and her team and the
people on the other end of the phone
some of whom i know
um and the whole process has been a
positive one
and guess what covid19
proved an unless an unhappy opportunity
for us to prove just how responsive and
helpful
we could be that is a tribute
to i have to say both baber and mid
suffolk
thank you council macro yes it gives
members confidence as well
that that we know that there is a good
and reliable
and friendly customer services team
there
backing everything up so it makes makes
our life better as well
thank you um councillor carter
yep sorry for delay i was just
researching changing my bank
um yes
[Music]
while staying the team is great and if
we are doing well i still have to have
considering many of my constituents many
of
uh parish clerks i have spoken to and
residents who have the sticking point no
personal gripe
against the term of customer
when we are representing people and if
it is no matter how
we intend to use their words or how we
uh meant to use the word it is down to
how the
the person how the how the people we
represent
take it we have to be mindful of others
and not just how
what we what we mean by it so
customer services the customer service
mindset
very important but when we are talking
about
residents and constituents if it
could offend other people i'd like to be
referred to as a customer
i'd still prefer to alter it
even if it's just in a single report if
we can't do it as a council
um but other than that uh
the the dual skills
wonderful from what i could um hear from
presentation when i've been
screamed out by a toddler wonderful so
yeah well done everyone on how how
things are improving
thank you um councillor sean dawson
um yes well i i don't want to embarrass
myself so i should just sort of
whispering on i'll just say thank you
it's it's it's
been very interesting and i think
there's any more to add anyone else has
said
thank you very much councillor osborne
are you there
yes thank you miss jeremias i am here
right
do you have anything to add no
well only that i can i can remember
going back a very long time now when
when the customer services set up was uh
a little bit more face to face and uh
there i remember memories of of
confusion by some of
our constituents on on certain subjects
which
uh have been well and truly rectified
over the last
uh few years so uh i'm all in
you know i mean absolute awe of what the
work
has been done by sam and the team um
i think i think it's you know the
figures
represent themselves and and as from uh
councillor carter's
remarks about whether they'd be called
customers or what
uh that has been brought up on numerous
occasions by
by members at committee so anyway
from all of that thank you sam and and
your team
thank you thank you very much um
has anybody got any uh suggestions by
way
of a recommendation
um i mean we've we've said we've said
such things as
i mean maybe just ask
members again if anybody have any more
to say on the subject before we move on
to recommendations
please thanks sorry does anybody else
have any anything to add to the debate
before we
look at recommendations just one point
yes please and it was in reference to
councillor scarf's um
an elderly mother i have also have an
elderly mother and i just like to
say that we shouldn't categorize any
group of people
according to their i.t skills simply on
the basis of age i have a
similarly aged parent who can be
described as a silver surfer
uh has a variety of electronic devices
at her disposal not quite as many as a
modern counsellor
but still uh she's she's more than happy
to uh to fly around the internet at any
available opportunity
all right i will admit occasionally with
mixed results
but the attitude is there so we
shouldn't just uh categorize people in
terms of an age group there are going to
be younger people
that have other actual access issues
that we should consider
in the same group as the one the
councillor scarf is referring to it's
not the
age or anything else or any particular
other subcategory
it's the actual ability or desire
to do so so scarf's point is well made
it just shouldn't be confined to one
particular group
thank you and and also the affordable
affordability of
the space that people feel that they
need is necessary
or as many of us have discovered
sometimes it's bandwidth
yes anyway does anybody else have
any comment to make before we look to
recommendations
no thank you has anybody got
uh suggestions for putting into a
recommendation
well i mean
i was asked a question by a member of
this
as to why there was no report today and
i explained the circumstances
and broadly speaking we've been looking
at this we've been monitoring this
process as mentioned by sam
since 2017 in various aspects of it and
it's an ongoing process so the real
question before the committee is
how much what level of continued
reporting
updating or presentations does this
committee require
and if it does require anything when
does it require it and i think that's
very much a question for the committee
because we have this is an ongoing
process it's not going to stop
nor should it the question is have the
committee as such taken as far as we can
or is there more we can add it can we
still add value this is the key point
and that really is the matter for the
chair and the committee
um well yes i mean
do members generally think a visit to
the customer access points would still
be a useful
uh a useful visit yes i would
yeah okay
um i i mean i i feel
we should we should by way of
introduction to the
uh any sort of recommendation or
proposal perhaps
thank the corporate manager for her
presentation and
perhaps comment commend the work of the
whole of the customer services team
and note the significant improvements in
the last three years
because they have been they have been
significant
um the whole customer service
response has has changed completely in
the last three years
um uh largely down to
um down to the corporate manager but
also
all of the staff within that team
uh councillor scarf you've got your hand
raised
thank you jenny yes but i would i would
echo that um
i think that it would be useful when
it's
possible for us to actually do it under
the covered 19
current circumstances to actually visit
the customer access points
it was something that we determined
earlier in the year was a good idea and
i don't think it's any
less of a good idea now than it was then
um in regards of um how this committee
looks at this issue in the future
i think things have moved on so quickly
since 2017
that actually it would be useful if we
just had a
maybe a yearly quick update from
samantha
uh and her team regarding the um
level of calls you know regarding the
response times and that kind of thing so
we can just
monitor uh for our own assurance i think
and for our residents assurance that
things are still moving in the right
direction
tremendous strides have been made but i
think we want to see that that progress
continues
and also as councillors monitor the way
that our residents actually contact
our two local authorities as well so i
think maybe um
we could have a further slide
presentation in a year's time i think
that would be tremendously useful i'd
like to see that as part of the
recommendation chair and be happy to
propose that thank you i see there are
nods around
uh councillor muller thank you chair no
i would totally concur with what
counselor scarf has said
and i'm happy to second his proposal
thank you
thank you very much councillor grandin
yes i i'd be
i'm happy to support councillor scarf
there too
i think this is such an important area
because um
everything we've had the presentation on
today
um is the public face of the council
and so it's of such central
importance really to everything that we
do um
the website the calls everything that
goes on there
is actually um along with us ourselves
representing the council to the public
so i think it's so
vital that this is as best as we can
ever get it at every stage
so yes i think it's important that it's
on
the agenda to be regularly visited so
that we can keep it to a standard that
we can be proud of
because um it is so central to
everything
that we do it everything that we do
is is represented by this public faith
so
um yeah i think it's very important
thank you
um i believe i see an officer hand
raised
um you see hello
yeah hello councillor uh william it's uh
sarah wilcock
um yes i just wanted to pick up
on um the comments that you that you've
been raising
with respect to um hearing something
back in a year's time
um whilst absolutely we would be more
than happy to
um to bring further updates to you i am
just conscious that
with regard to our quarterly performance
monitoring
quite a bit of the information that
you're referring to
in terms of volume of calls
progress that we're making in customer
satisfaction is reported already on a
quarterly basis
um so you know we can we can provide
a summary of that at the end of the year
but just wondered whether there's
something perhaps a little bit more
specific um that you would like us to
to cover rather than the sort of the
generalist
overview of performance that that we do
report already on a quarterly basis
that's available to everybody
thank you very much um
does uh councilman crawl well it's just
answering the point that that sarah has
just made is that obviously one of the
principles we've operated on over the
last few years is
to avoid duplication of effort those
quarterly performance reviews and the
key performance indicators appear uh in
the cabinet papers
every quarter and in fact they're
absolutely vital for all aspects of the
council not least customer service
so i recommend them to anybody that has
a spare
fifteen thirty two or three hours
whatever um
to go through on a quarterly basis they
really are helpful
uh question is where can we do something
that isn't already being done
and i think that is very much the point
that the committee should address
is it is it more to do with feeling
confident
seeing seeing customer services face to
face
in a in a meeting is that what people
want to see i mean i
i i i fully accept what sarah said that
all of the data is there the statistics
is there something beyond the statistics
that uh that people want to see casa
osborne
yeah thank you thank you mr chairman um
just a just a small point and a very
small point and
it has caused does cause confusion
are at access points now uh
um sam has identified them as access
points
between stone between stone market and
and sudbury however a lot of people that
comes out and even with
with our town council they use the word
advice centers
they are access points that's just a
very small point
and uh hopefully that can be
rectified at some point um other than
that
um yeah i i would
i'll go along with with what uh the the
position of keith
uh has just uh mentioned keith council
keys golf
um and that is that um we have a
we do have a a problem at times with
with face-to-face stuff and i think a
lot of
our cust well i shouldn't say customers
a lot of our constituents
do uh hopefully um look at the points
that uh they can actually get get things
addressed
uh as we've been doing now and they
they'd like to see obviously
statistics is the only thing really that
you can show
that has been improvements or there's
been a
a lowering of the standards but again
i've got no other comments thank you
keith
so i mean the the point that uh
councilman mccoy raises
is if we had a paper or a presentation
how can we add value
is it is it a presentation for
information
um is it a written presentation in the
form of an information bulletin
but whatever it is in whatever format
how will it how will it help
uh council scarf thank you chair i mean
i
i i don't want to make undo work for the
officers but i i do feel that
the way that we've received the
presentation today in terms of
uh trends of how people contact
us and how we deal with it is actually a
far
more useful uh format specifically for
councillors to understand than perhaps
the quarterly reports that go to cabinet
um an information bulletin might be
the way forward uh at the next meeting
and i'd be quite happy if that was the
way forward because i think that that
would
address the issues and would enable us
just to see
the continued progress that we all
expect
that this uh section will actually make
in in delivering services for
both councils and so i'm quite happy for
an information bulletin to be the the
way forward
and i think that's that's a good way for
scrutiny to deal with it thank you
thank you so would that be a an
information bulletin when
all the facts and figures of the the
next
full year have been uh can be aggregated
so
would that be say in around july
2021 yes yes thank you jay if that's
possible
uh councillor mccraw well actually i
think councillor scarf has just hit the
nail on the head
today's presentation sam you've just
made more work for yourself
was absolutely uh what we wanted to see
what we needed to see
provided the broad overview did so in a
reasonable length of time
i would think that what we're really
suggesting is that yes the information
the hard facts some
some figures are good but we get those
on a quarterly basis
but this presentation was uh
well i would say from my point of view
this was the best thing we've seen on
the subject for
some time and that we would like a
repeat performance is that all right
with you sam
i mean i don't know if sarah feels
differently and that we're asking a lot
of you
but on the other hand you're obviously
passionate about it
that passion needs to be communicated
and this would be a good forum for that
to take place
i think that in itself is the value
we're looking for
uh thank you councillor mcgraw i wonder
if i could just jump in
there uh councillor uh
would certainly be more than um more
than happy to
to bring back that that summary in a in
a in a way that
has obviously resonated with with
yourselves today
um i think one of the things that i was
sort of reflecting on and particularly
hearing
uh from all of your comments is is
definitely
uh the the reassurance and confidence in
terms of our face-to-face model
moving forwards and um
you know what i'm what i'm hearing from
yourselves is
is exactly as as we have talked about
um at the briefing recently and as part
of our management team meetings in terms
of
how do we continue to support our
customers in a face-to-face environment
but equally supporting those that
can get online to to go online and
reflecting back the many positives that
those that gives to our
um our residents across the two
districts so
i do wonder whether something for us to
particularly focus on
perhaps in an update is just around that
face-to-face element
sam has confirmed that that is something
that we are going to be looking at over
the next few months particularly
particularly thinking about how we've
worked in partnership with
voluntary organizations over the last
few months in supporting communities as
a responsive covid and that's something
that we really want to build on
with our customer face-to-face model so
in terms of
um we can certainly bring back a summary
of what you've heard today but perhaps
with a particular emphasis around
our face-to-face customer services would
be particularly helpful
yeah so that's that sounds that sounds
good councilman
claron thank you chair yes um having
just emphasized about the face-to-face
um benefits i would welcome
a yearly report with a face-to-face
relationship with the customer services
team
i think it's been most helpful today and
the personal
touch and the personal presentation
enhanced all the figures that were being
presented
thank you chair thank you very much and
councillor grandin
yes i must apologize i should have asked
this question before because it's not
quite relevant
to this this point of the meeting
so i apologize for for my timing but um
libraries and so on are now
open i believe so i just wondering um
are the face-to-face meeting
have they now resumed the face-to-face
pop-ups and so on
have they now resumed um so
just to answer that question and the
libraries have opened um for a select
and collect service so they have asked
that we do not
provide services in those locations at
present
and just due to the restrictions and we
are working with the libraries
um we haven't opened our face-to-face
services
um just because we are undertaking this
work to look at how we will deliver
those in the best way
taking into account some of the digital
skills work that we also want to deliver
however where we have needed to provide
emergency appointments to customers we
have done so and will continue to do so
um until we are kind of looking
at the the sort of broader plans around
our face-to-face services over the
coming months
and so may i just ask further will
um will you be making a sort of
publicized announcement as to when they
will be
back into normal service then
we will be looking to share that yes
absolutely in due course and we will
make sure that that is communicated
clearly to everybody
and externally as well our customers as
well yeah
thank you thank you i see
no hands raised um but if i can
if i can summarize what i think people
have been saying and then if somebody
would like to pick it up as a proposal
um and and somebody second it that would
be great um
the notes i have here are that we thank
the corporate manager
for her presentation and commend the
work of the
customer services team noting
significant improvements
in the last three years that we asked
for a visit
to be arranged when it is safe to do so
to customer access points
and we request a presentation uh
to update the committee in 12 months
time focusing on face-to-face
contacts is that the sort of thing you
have in mind cancer scarf
i think you've summed that up very well
chairman i would like to propose that
thank you very much do i have a seconder
counselor
um so are you happy then that we we do a
roll call
um a roll call to um by way of a vote
for this please
so that being the case yes i'll ask the
government's officer
to conduct the role call vote please
thank you chair i do apologize if you
can hear my dogs in the background i
think your hopes have been delivered i
do
apologize for that right so i will do a
roll call in alphabetical order
and um if you can please reply with for
against or abstain
thanks counselor carter
four
councillor dawson four
councillor grandin four
councillor hedingham four councilman
crawl
four council mclaren
council mclaren are you in mute
it's going oh god council mclaren
i think you're on mute again
yes can you hear me yes i can paul
thank you councillor muller
councillor osborne four
councillor scarf
and cancer willem and that is
unanimous and so that's carried thank
you very much
and thank you very much indeed samantha
for your presentation
that was great thank you and thanks for
answering all our questions
thank you everyone thank you can we now
move on to item nine on the agenda
which is the um forthcoming decisions
list
has everybody had an opportunity to
look at the forthcoming decisions list
is that anything on there
that you feel should be brought forward
as
an item for scrutiny
no comments
uh so we will note the forthcoming
decisions list
and we'll move on to the agenda item
of the work plans um so agenda item 10
is the baba over scrutiny committee work
plan for
20 20 21 and
we need to add as the
august item on the weber work plan
the august item from the mid-suffolk
work plan which is
agenda item 11 and
we're proposing that that would be a
joint meeting
so the same two items 20th of
august and we move that or
include that into the labor work plan
could you specify chair which items
those are those items
are planning enforcement review
of service transformation work
and that will be presented by the chief
planning officer
and the future delivery model for public
realm
which will be presented by the assistant
director for environment
and commercial partnerships and we
we've put that in there because the
um public realm delivery model will be
going to i think it's cabinet is it
september yeah
so are you happy that we
well i from the point of view of adding
that making it a joint meeting
uh i believe that would be the best
thing to do it's a matter that affects
both
councils and uh meeting jointly makes
sense
and as far as the members are concerned
i hope they'd agree
um henrietta you've got your hand raised
yes chair um i'm sorry i'm going to
confuse matters a little bit
you skipped an item on the agenda the
review of the work of the overview and
scrutiny committee i'm sorry
you would need to uh let members of the
public know that you have removed that
item or has been agreed to remove that
item from the agenda i do apologize and
then we can return to the work plans
yes okay yes um i item eight on the
agenda was the review of the work of the
overview and scrutiny committees
for twenty nineteen twenty this item has
been withdrawn
after the agenda was published as the
chairs of both overview and scrutiny
committees
decided that a different format for this
review would be con
considered so i apologize for that
we have dealt with item 9 and we're in
the middle of items 10
and 11. so if if we can now
uh return to to item 10 which is the
baber
work plan counselor mccraw well this
harks back to both if we are agreed that
we're going to do a joint meeting in
august
but it does relate both to the review
of overview and scrutiny which isn't
taking place in this meeting
but i'd like to ask if all members have
had an opportunity to
examine and to read the uh
annual report of either baber overview
and scrutiny or mid-suffolk overview and
scrutiny
that appears in the council papers for
this week's meetings
tomorrow at baber and thursday i think
at mid-suffolk
if you haven't it is a summary of the
entire year's work a very difficult year
for both mid-suffolk and baber's
overview and scrutiny
mostly meeting jointly and all i was
going to say
is this is i'd like to draw your
particular attention to the thanks
contained in the forwards uh the thanks
are given
to officers to members of the council
and cabinet members particularly
to the members of these two committees
without whom none of this could have
happened we've uh
all been working together for the whole
of the year in very difficult
circumstances so
i on my personal note i'd like to take
the opportunity of thanking members of
the committee
for everything they've done during this
year
but i think i'd give particular thanks
to a couple of officers
to which henriette holloway our
government support officer
and jan robinson uh our deputy
monitoring officer who keeps us on the
straight and narrow
so i'd like you all to say uh thank you
to both henriette
and to jan and to officers in general
and also pat yourselves on the back
yes yes thank you very much indeed yes
yeah i completely agree with that i'm
sure we all agree
that we have been extremely well
supported by officers
and more recently also by by mandia
and and robert who have had a role to to
play in virtual meetings and
quite correct yes so thank you to them
as well
i was going to say don't forget those
yeah
oh yeah got to remember the vice chairs
as well
and and my co-chair over at mid-suffolk
keith's all right i mean you know
i would mention everybody by name but
those three would pretty
annoyed if i didn't you you'll obviously
be annoyed if i don't mention you by
name though no that's not possible
that's not problem
not a problem is it i'll do it myself
and thank you and thank you to the vice
chairs
so henry you've got you've got a hand
raised uh i'm sorry chair
i forgot to lower it and we're just
going to remind you of that
item so but thank you very much for um
for your praise thank you much
appreciate it well deserved
so can we confirm um
the agenda items 10 11 the work the work
plans
i focus those we've noted those with
those additions and amendments
um and if that it and and we can
well we can move on to the end of the
meeting certainly
yeah so thank you very much that
concludes
that concludes the meeting then and the
time data time of the next meeting will
be a joint meeting and it will be on
monday
the 24th of august 2020 and will
commence at 9
30. so thank you all very much indeed
thank you bye thank you thank you
everyone bye
you